oh this lady talked like an Oscar winner
because she is we're talking about Anne
Hathaway and in her new movie colossal
she plays a hard-drinking party girl now
while that may sound like a real stretch
rant I mean look at her she's always put
together so perfectly
Carly Steele discovered there's a side
of an we never seen before what is the
craziest thing you've done when you've
been an abraded here's a problem I don't
remember
it's always that horrible feeling when
you wake up the next morning and your
phone shows that you've called someone
or not you did not mean to call that
that's probably the one that's making me
blush right now it's still embarrassing
and you're like I don't what did I said
we talk not what we expected to hear
from the notoriously private miss
Hathaway but Ann's lettin loose in this
crazy sci-fi comedy where she discovers
she can somehow control a gigantic
monster rampaging through Seoul Korea
it's dancing is dancing like highs off
to you you were expecting while filming
this and it's pretty physical yeah
was that one that I always want to do it
you know just as fast as the boys too
strong and I couldn't this time because
I had had a little little person in my
tummy and we did one take of the fight
there's a big fight in this thing
something else we discovered about Ian
she's got a scene with Rihanna in the
all-female crew of the upcoming ocean
date movie and it turns out and a total
fan girl
Rihanna please
you don't realize it how often you sing
Rihanna song just like under your breath
Wow
yeah you know like you just like and
that happened to me a couple times where
I started a song and just kind of had to
cut it off really fast because it was so
inappropriate I've caught a shot
[Music]
you